[Music]
the higher UK the harder it gets
that's life
because this is a war
there's a fight it's a battle
so
how long have you known each other
[Music]
it was like brothers
one day you came back the past came back
too
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back
not what he's doing now
[Music]
before I got locked up I was the best
you a coward bro and a fraud try to
spending half your life in a Cell
watching somebody else live your life
love
you can store it little bro
I'm coming for it all
it's not gonna stop
and you make it
the one and only Adonis Creed you're the
best pound fighter in the world 3 years
ago it's been a minute since you've been
out in these streets when I walked away
from boxing I walked away with some
unfinished business
you see that man right there
do you remember him hey hey
no friends in the industry I had to draw
the line between my brothers and my
enemies
I'll let him destroy everything you've
found
everything we've built
[Music]
between my brothers and my enemies
start fighting